so the Living Tribunal makes its first
full on appearance and Marvel Comics and
strange tales issue number 158 but
what's actually interesting here is that
strange tales issues number 156 57 58
and 59 we're actually part of the sort
of ongoing combined story whereby dr.
strange encounters a phone named Umar
the unmentionable and by virtue of being
unable to defeat Umar on his own
releases a multi-dimensional being named
zom and what we see is that when zom is
released of course dr. strange attempts
to stop zom after a zombie gets to run
amok and the Living Tribunal appears
almost immediately the Living Tribunal
dispatches zom fairly quickly and then
decrees to dr. strange that zom or I'm
sorry that the planet Earth has to be
destroyed from here we see dr. strange
pleading with a living tribunal asking
the Living Tribunal why it is that the
Living Tribunal has simply just arrived
here and passed judgment without
offering any or without allowing dr.
strange to present any real case here we
see the Living Tribunal responding to
Doctor Strange telling him that the laws
the sort of law and order court system
type of scenario that we have here on
the planet Earth has no real bearing on
the Living Tribunal that the Living
Tribunal exists beyond dimensions and
therefore does not really care about the
wishes and wants of the inhabitants of
the planet Earth but we also see that
the Living Tribunal wants to sort of
show dr. strange what it is that he's
done that has led to this circumstance
whereby Earth has to be destroyed now of
course this is really just Marvel giving
us a chance to understand that bigger
picture and to simply just give us a
chance to see things from a living
tribunals perspective and what we see is
that by virtue of Doctor Strange
releasing zom in order to help him
defeat
umar that dr. strange has a sort of
upset this cosmic balance
now what this cosmic balance is we don't
really understand yet but what we see is
that the Living Tribunal goes as far as
to decree that his three faces have
judged against the planet Earth and
Doctor Strange now this is very
important when it comes to the Living
Tribunal and the reason why
is because all three phases of a Living
Tribunal have to agree on a judgment in
order for that judgment to to be passed
in order for that judgment to be
implemented and what we see is that the
first unshredded face the face that we
can fully see is the face of equity and
this is the face of the Living Tribunal
that pertains to being just that
pertains to being unbiased the second
face is the face of revenge this is the
face of the Living Tribunal which seeks
out - to implement or I guess to affect
those or to judge those that it receives
to have harmed them or to have
intentionally done something to upset
the cosmic balance of a particular
dimension universe or a reality the
third face and the completely shrouded
face is the face of necessity and this
is simply the face that represents the
fact that something needs to be done
about this particular action and in
order again in order for the Living
Tribunal to actually implement judgment
that all three of these faces have to
agree on the fact that some judgment
needs to be implemented in order for the
Living Tribunal to act from here we get
an explanation of what it was what kind
of cosmic imbalance dr. strange had
created that required the actions of a
Living Tribunal and what we learn is
that when all realities were created
when all dimensions have either come
into existence currently or had
previously been created that in terms of
dr. Strange's place and the cosmos and
in the multi and the multiverse that he
is simply but one facet that every
single dimension has a master of the
mystic arts more or less the dimension
of Dormammu houses Dormammu himself who
is the master of the mystic arts within
his own dimension and someone is so
forth then what we see is that by virtue
of dr. strange releasing zom that dr.
strange has created a circumstance
whereby there are now two masters of the
mystic arts more or less in the same
dimension and the problem with this is
that it's upset the cosmic balance and
so the Living Tribunal has decreed that
the planet Earth needs to be destroyed
in order to keep this from happening
again
what we see is that of course
dr. strange pleads with with the Living
Tribunal telling the Living Tribunal of
that not all hope is lost that the earth
isn't necessarily this place that
inherently and inherently houses evil
that it's a place that can be saved and
so of course we see the Living Tribunal
at the end of strange tales issue number
158 offering a circumstance or offering
a opportunity to dr. strange to save the
planet Earth where dr. strange can take
a period of time to demonstrate that the
earth is not beyond saving that the
earth is an inherently good place which
of course he is successfully able to do
and the Living Tribunal withdraws now
from here we switch forward several
years to the Silver Surfer vol 3
issue number 31 and all this really does
is I give us a better understanding of
the faces of the Living Tribunal and
what we learn here is that the faces of
the Living Tribunal are not absolute
that is to say the faces of vengeance
necessity and equity are not an absolute
standard in terms of how they're
perceived that an individual that looks
upon the Living Tribunal will see the
faces of vengeance necessity and equity
relative to their stance and their life
experiences within the Marvel cosmos and
so Doctor Strange would look upon these
three faces and see something vastly
different than what the Silver Surfer
would see now what we also see is a
several years later actually in 2006 we
switch over to she-hulk volume 2 issue
number 12 and what we see here is again
a little bit more of an expansion in
terms of the the Living Tribunal whereby
we learn about the fourth face of a
Living Tribunal and this is something
that I'd hope you noticed by this point
that the Living Tribunal has four sides
to its head but we only ever see three
faces what's really interesting about
this particular scenario is that the
Living Tribunal again rehashes the the
various the the three faces that he has
but then he mentions his fourth faces
hidden face and he tells she-hulk to
simply look upon his hidden face and
when she does she sees a reflection of
herself and what the what the letme
tribunal tells to her is that the I
guess the the fourth face is the face of
a mirror it's the cosmic mirror
which reminds people to always judge
others as they would have themselves
judged now whether or not this is Marvel
attempting to maybe set up some sort of
moral code or attempting to elevate the
Living Tribunal to being a reflection of
the one above all is something that
we're not entirely sure about if
anything I would go as far as to say
that this may very well be I guess a
step in a different direction that we
had seen and the Silver Surfer volume
three issue number 31 where I guess so
let me tribe you don't had told the
Silver Surfer that at one point in time
the fourth face could have represented
this stranger but regardless of the
circumstances the Living Tribunal is a
very I guess a very rigid in a very
absolute character and this is something
that I find pretty refreshing about his
role in the Marvel Universe that there
are a lot of characters whose
motivations whose mecha nations whose
desires in the Marvel Universe could be
interpreted could really be looked at in
a multitude of different ways and a
really subjective based on the
storylines based on the events that are
taking place so with a living tribunal
it's not that way the Living Tribunal
only shows up in times when the
multiverse or a particular universe is
threatened to the point that it upsets
some kind of cosmic balance now this
element of the Living Tribunal only
appearing when a cosmic balances has
been upset there's something I would
like for you to keep in the back of your
head because this will become very
important when we get into the Infinity
Gauntlet and we see eternity
I guess appealing to the Living Tribunal
and asking the Living Tribunal to
intervene regarding the actions of
Thanos possession of the Infinity
Gauntlet but again with regards to our
discussion about the one above all and
the Living Tribunal an important thing
to bear in mind here is that of course a
Living Tribunal is second to the one
above all but these two individuals
exists outside the realm of the of a
single universe they exist in a sort of
position to where they oversee
multiverses and while the Living
Tribunal exists to judge all the
multiverses and to ensure that cosmic
balances remain that you're talking
about characters who have such a high
caliber level of power that there really
is no difference between the two of them
that individuals in the Marvel Universe
would simply look upon both the one
above all and the Living Tribunal and
see them equally because their power
could only be quantified by simply
saying they can do everything there's
really no point in which you could say
one of them could do more than the other
of course I would go as far as to say
that the one above all could easily
eliminate the let me Tribunal being that
the one above all was the one who
created the Living Tribunal but again at
this point you're talking about a level
of power that's so extreme that there's
really no differentiation between how
how their powers would be perceived if
they ever were to use them to their full
extent with that being said this is
pretty much it when it comes to the
Living Tribunal again he's very rigid
he's very absolute in terms of his
stance in the Marvel Universe
and there really isn't a whole lot to
offer in terms of discussion in terms of
interpretation of the Living Tribunal
because it really isn't anything to
interpret he simply just exists to carry
out the judgement of the one above all
and to ensure that cosmic balances
remain in check so that no one universe
becomes a threat to any of the other
universes within the Marvel multiverse
with that being said I'm gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end to hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace